-Super Bowl LVII is this Sunday.
I am pumped for the game.
You have the Kansas City Chiefs
taking on
the Philadelphia Eagles.
You got Mahomes versus Hurts.
It's nearly impossible
to predict who's gonna win,
but you're in luck, because when
it comes to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon,
and it's puppies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Ladies and gentlemen, it is time
for the "Puppy Predictors:
Super Bowl LVII Edition".
-♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
-Welcome to the
"Puppy Predictors:
Super Bowl LVII Edition".
Here's how it works --
we have seven puppies,
we have two bowls of kibble,
one representing
the Kansas City Chiefs,
the other representing
the Philadelphia Eagles.
Whichever team's bowl gets
the most puppies will be crowned
the Super Bowl champs.
Now, let's meet the puppies.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, guys, focus up
and get ready.
Focus up.
Guys, let's meet them.
First, we have...
We have...
And of course...
Now, before I release you guys,
I need you to listen up, okay?
I want this to be a clean vote.
I don't want to see
any wandering, peeing,
or butt-sniffing, okay?
Gary! Gary!
No -- there's -- yes, Gary,
how are you?
You ready to go?
Who're you going for -- Eagles,
Chief, we don't know
what's happening.
Okay, here we go.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You prepared?
Okay.
Release the puppies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Early lead.
I think the winner
are the Eagles,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Gary.
Gary, don't lay down.
Gary, you're laying on the --
you want to lay down?
Come on, Gary, get up.
-[All] Aww!
-That's right, everyone,
the Eagles will be crowned
Super Bowl champions.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everybody, enjoy the game.
We'll be right back
with Paul Rudd, everyone.
Stick around. Good job.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪